[Music]
the first nutcrackers were plain purely
functional devices by the 15th century
European wood carvers began crafting
beautiful nutcrackers shaped like
animals and people german artisans
became known for their majestic
nutcracker kings and soldiers just like
the one in Chekhov's keys famous ballet
this German company has been crafting
character Nutcracker since 1928 like
porcelain figurines these nutcrackers
sell as limited edition collectibles at
hundreds of dollars each people don't
actually use them for the intended
purpose but they can and do perform the
job you simply manipulate a lever to
open then close the mouth to crack the
nut shell on the factory floor they use
a multi blade circular saw to cut all
the body parts out of Lindenwood Linden
is ideal because it's lightweight easy
to carve and its color is pale enough to
mimic skin these blocks are on their way
to become in Nutcracker torsos first
they go through a planer it trims the
four sides of each block forming an
octagonal shape
[Music]
from square to octagonal and next to
round but first workers use a circular
saw to cut the blocks into torso length
pieces a conveyor feeds the pieces one
by one into an automatic multi station
lathe the first station rounds out the
Octagon then forms the basic torso shape
the second station finalizes the shape
then the next four station sand the wood
smooth so that the wood stain they'll
ply later on will penetrate well and
evenly then the torsos go three at a
time into a vertical router it cuts a
notch in each one for the lever that
opens and closes the nutcrackers mouth
next stop is a drilling machine which
simultaneously drills all the holes
required to attach the body parts as
well as the levers axle now they dress
the torso in a coat which they create
simply by staining the wood a dark color
once the stain dries they spray on two
coats of semi gloss lacquer every
Nutcracker stands on a wooden base under
which they burn the company's logo it's
a mark of authenticity for collectors
the automatic lathe also shapes the
other body parts including the head
workers attach a nose then using a
router cut holes for the eyes then they
lightly spray on a touch of red paint to
simulate a sun-kissed nose and rosy
cheeks
then with the steady hand they paint the
whites of the eyes and the eyebrows once
the paint dries they apply some glue to
the center of each eye then affix an
iris and pupil made of enameled tin now
they align the head with the torso and
screw the parts together after
decorating the coat with buttons and a
buckle they glue a strip of rabbit fur
hair to the head a rabbit fur beard to
camouflage the knotch for the lever then
they mount the torso onto the legs which
were painted on boots and stand on the
base then this Nutcracker percussionist
gets his drum along with arms and
drumsticks they top them off with a hat
made of spray-painted wood
most of the nutcrackers parts joined
together with wooden dowels a large Dow
running across the notch in the torso is
the axle on which the lever rotates this
extensive cast of Nutcracker characters
comes in various sizes and you can even
special order a life-sized version
[Music]